to me the I got to say this and that's
going to be controversial when Bush was
president they came up with the terror
color the terror threat Al that was
helpful that is basically the Doomsday
Clock it's the same idea it's to scare
the out of you so that you will maybe um
agree to certain things that you were
uncomfortable agreeing to before I don't
think that this is like some like great
thing or whatever I think it's not that
it's
[Music]
fearmongering
what is the Doomsday Clock the [__] is
that is it a Mayan calendar the closer
it gets to midnight the the more close
we are to nuclear Annihilation yeah
basically by basically by man-made human
destruction so it's a 24-hour cycle like
every basically it's a clock and then
literally the closer the hand is to
midnight and it's determined every
single year every single year like once
a year they basically assess where the
they together yeah yeah it's kind of
like the national forest fire coloring
chart where it's like it's a it's a dry
summer then it's like kind of red or
like extremely flammable so so like
based off of like World man-made
destructive possibilities okay uh it's
almost like being like are we at DEFCON
5 deathcon 4 3 2 and then once a year
they determine this and then that will
basically be kind of a signal to the
world organizations and governments on
what we may may not need to do in
response to that type of judgment so
like it's time to kill the beefs between
A and B Yeah so basically the Doomsday
Clock for this year has just been
adjudicated if you will and is quote
unquote the closest it has ever been to
midnight is it like 11:59 thanks to who
huh thanks to who
58 thanks to
Biden U basically in the last couple of
years it's been at 100 seconds to
midnight and that has historically like
you said since whenever it was created
that has historically been the closest
to midnight ever so we were already on
that point yeah and I think the last two
years it stayed at 100 seconds this year
it just went to 90 Seconds To Midnight
can I can I ask you guys a question does
it all feel like that collectively in
your head yes it doesn't feel like the B
pics to me as far as like the news and
you know the way everything's kind of
trending you kind of feel like oh [__]
we're about to hit it always feels like
this huh yeah cuz you learn how many
nukes everybody has if you pay attention
to any news it always feels like this
and they they make sure of it it feels
different to me because we're not
dealing with the Soviet Union anymore to
me the I got to say this and it's going
to be controversial when Bush was
president they came up with the terror
[__] color code the terror threat Al
that was helpful that is basically the
Doomsday Clock it's the same idea it's
to scare the [__] out of you so that you
will maybe um agree to certain things
that you were uncomfortable agreeing to
before I don't think that this is like
some like great thing or whatever I
think it's not that it's
fearmongering that's my hot take do any
terrorist groups sense have nuclear
weaponry um not a terrorist group but
Iran is or do they have it yet so that's
what everyone's saying is they basically
have everything that it takes to build a
nuclear weapon and they might have it
already we don't know it's all Stark
industry stuff but that's what they said
about Iraq yeah and and and Iran
definitely is a bigger player cuz
because oh yeah we funded the [__] out
of them but it's fine and then there's
North Korea well they already have one
it's confirmed they got one they
definitely have a nuclear weapon we
don't know that they can launch it we
don't know that they can even like ICBM
it right well uh I guess Russia is our
main nuclear like threat right but mhm
this is what I don't understand about
the whole like adversary with them
because they're no longer Soviet Union
it crashed like in the 9s I don't
understand why we need NATO cuz NATO was
for the Soviet Union it was created for
all the countries to get
together like because of the Russian
because of Russia but after the Soviet
fall they kind of joined the rest of us
so I'm like why we we neutered the USSR
and then they fell and then new Russia
came in and then they kind of were just
like [__] show Boris yelton for a long
time and then now they're a global
player again because we basically said
we don't have any enemies anymore after
Al-Qaeda who's going to be the next big
threat mitt Ronney floated it during the
presidential campaign of 20 Russia and
12 against Obama he's like the biggest
threat right now is Russia and Obama
clowned on him and said the 1980s call
they want your foreign policy back W
yeah and like that but they they always
do what Joe called yesterday priming
they set you up to know the enemy for
the next thing that they're going to do
so you feel like you came up with it on
yourself and you're like I knew it it's
like no you didn't fool you got primed
into [__] believing it but then NATO
expansionism is why Russia invaded
Ukraine it's not great I'm not I'm not
happy about it I'm like oh this is
awesome and like I'm like no no no NATO
kept on creeping towards territories
they said they wouldn't they kept on
moving in and that's why we got to where
we got to and it's not good I'm not
happy that Putin did this [__] are you
kidding me although he saved me 100
Grand but also I I kind of get it from
that point of view cuz I'm like they
actually wanted to join right they
wanted to join they wanted to join all
of that stuff and they're like you can't
and we're like why and then you start
creating bases around doesn't that seem
like antagonizing bro they were
antagonizing the whole time but that's
what we always do right when we want to
move into the Middle East and take
everyone's oil we go Saddam Hussein has
all kinds of [__] up stuff that's
really messed up and he shouldn't have
it even though we all have it but he
shouldn't have it but we we should have
the oil cuz we'll we'll we'll use it
better yeah we'll use it better and
we'll sell all the oil contracts to
China yep cuz that helps America and
that's what they did but doesn't that
isn't that the reason why it feels like
it went from 100 to 90 like it's getting
closer and closer and closer to I think
on top of the Ukraine Rush War plus the
Israel Gaza conflict and China
constantly throwing a bomb NATO
mobilizing right now to square off
against Russia is why this happened NATO
just recently mobilized like within the
last like 72
hours yeah but what I don't get is like
why would you why would you like ruffle
feathers with a nuclear country well
because the Ukraine money is drying up
and they The Narrative is drying up and
so they need to do something about it
but it's
also technically still proxies right
meaning like there's no I don't actually
think that either one wants a war
directly like like no like it's not good
for the US or Russia just economically
but we're posturing so much like there's
ships and forces being sent and
mobilized like so it could be like World
War II I'll never claim to know again
because like I told Anthony when uh
before Putin went into Ukraine I was
like he's not going to do it cuz I
didn't think well you didn't listen to
Alex Jones did you not I did not I just
didn't think he would actually end up
doing it because it would put him under
such enormous International pressure and
I remember telling you that and then
when he did it I was like all right dude
I don't [__] know anything but yeah
but because of all of the above to me it
does feel like it's getting closer and
closer and closer to some crazy world
conflict seems pretty scary right now
hot tank what if this was an
inside handshake deal among Putin and
the Biden crime family and he said it's
just damn F and then Ukraine it said
this is the deal okay you guys have your
War we're going to have a little war bam
and then we're going to just pull back
and we're going to make a lot of money
doing it could be what it doesn't look
like we're going to make a lot of money
little
war because of the way that they have
nuclear arms that can actually like work
in a theater of war but Small Time mhm
I'm I'm too scared like you can launch a
nuclear warhead that's small and like
[__] up entire armies and it doesn't do
the same nuclear like hirosima effect
yeah so that's what scares me like the
mini ones it's not it's not big mushroom
it's small mushroom exactly it's little
inoi versus big Shake that's a big
difference cuz shitake can be like
whereas inoi like you see that in the
morning you take a [__] nuclear bomb
that could destroy barow instead of like
La bar is a huge economical and military
base for us yeah and the other part I
think that's kind of scary too is kind
of like the that whole like almost
anti-patriotism act yeah across
everywhere so I think when you have less
people believing then there's more
people pushing buttons now you know what
I mean if I can't send people well [__]
I just have to go down nuke nuk nuk nuk
nuk you I just start sending missiles
cuz I have less people to actually fight
the war so it just feels like there's
external and internal conflict it just
feels like the boiling point is like
it's rising to me well I mean the quote
unquote what what do they called the
atomic committee oh the the bulletin of
the atomic scientists who set the clock
made the announcement and they're the
ones that are pushing and saying hey the
Doomsday Clock is now 9 sex and
obviously we don't want that to get to
midnight but you know what I mean at
what point is it going to be enough of a
call to action to world leaders to like
figure out how to like slow that pace
down I have a hot take please do you
think it was more chill when Jeffrey
Epstein was around cuz he got everyone
[__] and coming and stuff and he had
them all under his finger but now you
you don't got people everyone's all pent
up you know they're like they got to
release that pressure Oh you mean them
Oh you mean like world leaders coming
cuz they saw J and come together what
did you think he meant no I thought it
it was like it's nice that he had them
all under his control so then now he can
just be like guys no war okay or else
I'm going to tell everybody that you
[__] oh I meant like he was like he was
letting the steam out of the tea kettle
for a lot of the world lead so bar wants
them to keep [__] the young ones not
the young ones in this world we might as
well doomsday ourselves then [__] it
plus I'm pretty sure there's many more
people just like him that still are
invisible franchise yep yeah he probably
is a protege of some other dude I did
finally watch sound of freedom on the
plane oh I need to watch that stuff yo
that [__] hurts you like it I didn't see
it like it it's about the EP people like
it but like human trafficking of
children right is it your favorite movie
now you watch every every every oh we're
out of time that's unfortunate did you
enjoy the soundtrack he bought the album
cuz it just wants to keep replaying it I
need to watch that man I think lizo did
the soundtrack
it Barts Barts off the seat we're right
time
[Music]
bro